[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Frances McDorman
three billboards
Frances McDormand won the Academy Award
for Best Actress on Sunday night for her
performance in three billboards outside
Epping Missouri I think I'll be alright
then but the star was separated from her
Oscar at the Governor's Ball according
to USA Today the 60 year old was seen
quote crying emotionally outside the
event and eventually gave up the search
for her missing statue which was
engraved with her name at the event
leaving with her husband filmmaker Joel
Coen now et can confirmed that a man
stole Francis's Oscar from her table he
was arrested and booked on felony grand
theft later that night the oscar winners
rep confirmed that she was back in
possession of the golden trophy saying
in a statement quote fran and oscar are
happily reunited and are enjoying an
in-and-out burger together if I fall
over pick me up because I've got some
things to say but before that all went
down Francis was praised for her
powerful speech where she asked all the
female nominees in every category to
stand up with her gentlemen because we
all have stories to tell and projects we
need finance